في البرازيل وفي ظل الانقسامات وايضا
الاضطرابات التي تعاني منها السلطه هناك
امل بان ينجح الرئيس المنتخب دا سيلفا في
حل الازمات التي يمر بها الشعب الا ان صار
الرئيس السابق بورسونارو يتربصون بالرئيس
المنتخب يتوعدون بالقيام باعمال العنف
اثناء اداء سيلفا اليمين الدستوريه بعد
ساعات قليله من الان وسط اجراءات امنيه
مشدده فبعد نجاحه في الانتخابات في اكتوبر
الماضي يشكك معارضوه وانصار الرئيس بول
سوناناروا بنزاهه الانتخابات وينظمون
الاحتجاجات دعينا الى انقلاب عسكري لمنعه
من الوصول الى السلطه من خلال اعمال
التخريب وايضا العنف طبعا الولايه ليست
الولايه الاولى لدرس سيلفا بل هي الثالثه
بعد ان امضي عاما ونصف العام في السجن
طبعا بتهم الفساد والتي تم اسقاطها لاحقا
الرئيس المنتخب بوجهه اقتصادا مثقلا
بالمصاعد والركود بالتزامن مع عماد حاده
في الشارع البرازيلي الا انه سبق وان
استطاع مواجهه متاعب مشابهه في الماضي نجح
في مساعده ملايين البرازيليين واخراجهم من
الفقر وايضا دعم الاقتصاد